anyway here with reaction in his very
unique style of ways our friend senator
john kennedy from the great state of
louisiana
you know senator i have a question for
you because you're a common sense guy
i'd like to i'd like to put aside
republican democrat i just want
americans to have a chance to be
successful
that's why i'm a conservative i think
conservatism works
so in all these years 35 years in radio
26 and a half years of fox
over those years i have seen a lot of
research on myself
and sometimes there's criticism from one
or two people i'll look at it i'll pay
attention to it but when there's a trend
of 15 20 30 people
maybe making the same criticism about me
in some way
i usually pay attention and i try to
change to be better at what i do
now if you have record high gas prices
you know that we've never seen before
now over five bucks a gallon and record
high inflation
the obvious answer would be to change go
back to the policies that you inherited
that work
why won't joe biden and his party even
consider the policy change shift that
would be needed
sean i don't know
some of my democratic colleagues have
raised age
as an issue for the president and my
judgment
age is the least of the president's
problems if he doesn't run for
reelection
in my opinion it will be because of his
unpopularity
um
i i don't think i'm
unlike most americans i think about 90 i
know about 90 of my
personal and political philosophy is uh
is don't hate
don't hurt someone unless you have to
defend yourself
don't take other people's stuff
and leave me alone
and and president biden obviously
disagrees he and his administration are
constantly screwing with the american
people telling them how to live their
lives
and they do so in a way that does not
improve the lives of most americans i
i'll give you a few examples president
biden
and the bad administration set the
department of justice on parents
who care enough about their kids to go
to a school board meeting and ask
questions
the bible administration called the
people of florida a bunch of bigots
because they don't want government
talking to their five-year-old children
about sexuality
the bad administration called the good
people of georgia racists
because they believe that you ought to
have to prove you are who you say you
are in order to vote
[Music]
just today
president biden gave a speech
and here's what he told the american
people
he told the american people that their
401ks have crashed
and the gas has gone from two dollars to
five dollars
because the economy is so good
no no no one believes that no one
believes that
and that's why i say that president
biden's
biggest challenge
in my judgment is not his age it's his
policies that said
now i want to take it to the next step
you gave me the answer about biden
but you're you're a pretty cordial
personable individual i'm sure you talk
to
people on the other side of the aisle
you may even have a good relationship
with many of them i would assume you
probably do
what about them
what are they saying about the high gas
prices what are they saying about joe
what are they saying about inflation
what are they saying about you know the
state of the economy
uh the border uh all of these issues are
they not seeing what is so plainly
obvious to everyone else
well when it when it becomes time to
talk about president biden's policies
you couldn't find
well let me put it another way
dog the bounty hunter couldn't find most
of my democratic colleagues when you
want to talk about
president biden's
administration and his family but joe
manchin kristen cinema they seem to be
people you can work with they seem
reasonable um they've been they bucked
their party and they said no when we're
not going along with some of these
policies
i give them credit for doing so they've
taken a lot of heat for doing it
yes but but uh
but they don't criticize the president
now maybe they do privately
but what my biggest surprise in the past
six months
particularly after the virginia
governor's race is that this
administration instead of instead of
course correcting has doubled down
and at this juncture i can tell you that
most americans look at this
administration
how can i put this they think they think
andy has left town and barney is in
charge
um or maybe otis there are young kids
notice the drunk no
there are some people that have no idea
that you're talking about mayberry usa
they don't know
well they should watch the uh series and
they might they might learn something
they might you know it's interesting and
i've i've said this before it's worth
repeating in my view
after the midterm shellacking and
hillary care care failed and
they didn't have a good first midterm uh
bill clinton in 1994 when newt when the
republicans came to power on the
contract with america newt gingrich's
vision
you know
bill clinton then adjusted the era of
big government is over and it's the end
of welfare as we know it he also had
what we described as a sister soldier
moment
i don't see that capacity in any
democrat but for the two i mentioned
do you
no but here's the difference between the
clinton and the biden administrations
uh president clinton appointed what
one commentator
uh called this week
a bunch of
high iq stupid people in other words
they were well educated but no common
sense
president biden has appointed
whack jobs i mean it's like these people
dropped acid in an outback parking lot
you can't reason with them
that they they they are just so awoke so
woke and that's the difference in my
opinion and why they haven't course
corrected all right senator we need you
back in the senate i know the good
people of louisiana uh will gladly pull
the lever for you and vote for you we
appreciate you being with us thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else